back for more the hacked off Prince
hoping to expose the tabloids the irony
of a privacy case that all the
embarrassment is relived today questions
about visiting a lap dancing club in his
early 20s cavorting at a rugby match
untrue says Harry and the breakup with
an old flame Chelsea Davey over 15 years
ago
because cameras aren't allowed in court
we've used an actor to portray what was
said hurray Harry's dump was
hurtful to say the least such a private
moment was turned into a bit of a laugh
the fact that payments were referenced
to project Harry is incredibly
disturbing yeah it's the level of
surveillance I was under was quite
something
Harry is referring to payments to
private investigators he believed were
used to dig up stories using unlawful
methods including phone hacking which he
claims also contributed to this article
about his relationship with TV presenter
Caroline Flack
the story makes it very clear that the
photographers were there before I got
there they saw me arriving on this
evening that was strictly between myself
and Caroline who is no longer with us
and my friend Mark Dyer
and three of us communicated over the
phone leaving each other voicemails as
to how that poker night was going to
happen
while all the focus is on him he has to
turn the spotlight on the newspapers the
Battleground in this courthouse is 33
articles that Prince Harry says were
obtained using illegal information
gathering the mirror group lawyer has
often been able to demonstrate that
other newspapers are running the stories
or there may have been legitimate ways
of gathering that information and the
question was could Prince Harry
demonstrate that some of that
information was obtained through hacking
or blagging blagging is obtaining
information by deception or
impersonation I think Harry's land is
some punches in relation to the actual
evidence that he'll need to prove his
case
um for example some of the
investigations that were conducted by
private investigators and the fact that
some of the payments to those
investigators were labeled as for
example Chelsea watch and Harry project
for example the Chelsea watch in
relation to the breakdown of their
relationship that's the kind of evidence
that will be crucial because he needs
that kind of evidence rather than
circumstantial evidence
Harry talks of a tracking device placed
on his ex-girlfriend's car stalker
photographers knowing where he'd be what
he couldn't do on the cross-examination
was point to specific hacked messages
that led to stories appearing in papers
but questioned by his own lawyer he said
this
I remember a lot of missed calls that
lasted one second
I remember a lot of people asking me did
you get my voicemail
but I do not remember how consistent it
was
but what I was told about the fact that
this was hacking it all made sense after
giving evidence Prince Harry stayed in
court to watch one of his alleged
tormentors The Mirror's former Royal
correspondent Jane Kerr give evidence
she'd written 10 of the 33 contentious
articles and the court was told she'd
commissioned private investigators 900
times while at the mirror but Jane Kerr
couldn't recall all of her sources for
these stories she claimed some came from
other newspapers such as this drug one
and she denied asking third parties to
do anything unlawful but admitted she
didn't check they weren't this is coming
home to roost at last in the shape of
Prince Harry because here they've
they've they've got an opponent who
really is not worried about winning
money he's worried about winning the
argument
in a day and a half of cross-examination
Prince Harry sometimes floundered but
has also left questions hanging about
how papers got certain bits of private
information about him and for an
organization known to have hacked phones
over that time period why wouldn't they
hack one of their best story makers
Jason Farrell Sky News